[Musique]
la plupart des gens savent que vous émettez beaucoup de
virus à travers les particules respiratoires et
les gouttelettes des poumons, mais en fait,
ce qui est moins connu, c'est que vous
émettez en fait plus de particules fécales plus virales
dans les matières fécales que dans les
poumons, donc en gros, nous utilisons  qui
suit essentiellement les mouvements des gens dans les toilettes
[Musique]
et nous pouvons simplement surveiller la quantité de
virus essentiellement morts dans les eaux usées
et l'utiliser comme un outil de surveillance pour
déterminer essentiellement combien de personnes dans
la population que vous connaissez ont protégé
leur maladie deuxièmement vérifier si
des choses comme les mesures de verrouillage fonctionnent
[Musique]
vous pouvez imaginer qu'avec diverses parties du
réseau d'égouts, nous pourrions
collecter des échantillons fécaux essentiels de
centaines de milliers, voire de millions de
personnes et nous permet donc d'avoir une
idée du niveau d'infection à travers un
grand  population sans avoir à
sortir et à frapper à la porte de chacun
individuellement et à demander un échantillon individuel
Je comprends parfaitement les craintes des gens qu'il
n'y a pas de peur toutes les preuves que nous
avons sont que c'est par transmission de personne à personne
par des gouttelettes respiratoires
lorsque le virus pénètre  le système d'égouts
est désactivé et essentiellement ouais
il n'y a aucun risque pour la santé publique sur les
eaux usées
[Musique]